[Music]
end of watch is very uh intense there's
an intensity i think it's that's hard to
to capture in these films because you've
seen so many police movies but this one
does uh i was watching it uh late at
night and then couldn't sleep afterwards
it's it's got that kind of yeah thank
you
so i was cranky with my kids the next
day and now my wife is leaving me but
that's another story
but to prepare for this you you uh did
the thing i've heard of actors doing
this you rode with the lapd is that
right we spent five months on the
streets with lapd two or three times
lapd sheriff's department and angle
would pd you know two or three times a
week like 4 p.m to 5 a.m in the morning
we did probably over 50 ride-alongs with
with law enforcement in last where where
are you
riding in the car are you in the front
seat are you in the back seat where
where they put the criminals yes we're
in the back seat right there's usually
only two seats in the front of the car
yeah and that's left for the officers so
um we were in the back how dare you
speak to me this way
i just i just
i know you think i should guide you
along i know you think you're in great
shape but you haven't felt what's under
ah
i just thought you were trying to attack
me today did it feel like pudding in
there
did it feel like someone had put frozen
yogurt in the sleeve of a suit just
don't try and get that close to me again
i'm going to respect the healing hall
sphere
it's full of lingenberries and swedish
meatballs
uh so you're you're riding with these
guys did you did they ever make any
arrests while you were in the car and
then they're getting arrested and it's
five in the morning and jake gyllenhaal
gets out of the bag they're like sorry
guys we need the back see you later uh
yeah we went through a lot we went
through a lot with the police officers i
mean we witnessed a lot of things i mean
the very first ride-along i was on there
was someone was murdered which was which
was a very tough thing to see and then
you know a lot of other things along the
way for five months on the streets with
you know police officers in the
southeast side of los angeles you're
going to see a lot of things and i
imagine it goes without saying you come
away with a new respect for how these
people what they're up against and what
it's like to be living like that every
day professionally i would say it's
beyond respect yeah i mean to be a first
responder in situations and to have to
deal with some of the things that they
deal with you know and also on the
opposite side i think you know i see
it's a brotherhood you know and for us
the biggest thing in the movie was that
the stuff that goes on inside the car
before they actually respond to a call
is a great stuff it's full of you know
they're always joking around and then as
soon as a call comes in you know they're
focused on the job at hand but the best
stuff ins is inside the car you know
with the with two best friends
essentially when you're riding a car
with them there are some very funny
moments in the in the movie that are
natural they're real it's not like
they're not gags it's they come out
they're they're character driven but
there's a great scene where you're at uh
your wedding your character's wedding
and you're break dancing yes and you do
a complete break dance routine yes i am
how do you feel about your you look at
it now are you feeling good about your
breakdance routine i expected a bigger
response from that one yes i do
breakdance
i've never seen an audience applaud as
they're filing out
that's actually what happens when i
break dance
they face
it's a really fun scene uh but it looked
like you guys really worked out a good
routine you know we did yeah me and anna
kendrick yeah we get married in the
movies plays your wife and she is an
incredible dancer i have to say and so i
just was following her lead but there's
one moment in the dance where i actually
have to do it all myself and i do do a
little spin move on the floor there is a
lot of very nice like you say you've
created a nice environment in the police
car you you feel that these are real
police officers who like each other
they're real people they know each other
and we have a clip here from a funny
moment i believe i don't know if this is
a moment from the car from the uh police
station this isn't in the car but it
isn't the police station we're filling
out paperwork which my character says is
the lifeblood of the organization which
a lot of people don't you know in movies
you always see the action you see what's
going on but in this movie at times you
get to see what a real police officer
has to deal with and most of the time
it's a lot of paperwork and a great deal
of boredom so yeah this is what happens
in a little little event that happens in
the uh in the uh
you know in the office uh end of watch
let's take a look at this clip
yeah i heard he took a shot at you okay
yeah i'm fine good he's good
liberace's ak this looks like liberace's
ak
keep up the good work guys i really
appreciate it carry on thank you hey
good evening sir good night evan houser
evening sir
why do you get nervous women want a men
want to be in man he's just yeah i know
but you want him dude i'm not gay but
i'd go down on him if you ask
[Music]
sometimes i don't know when you're
kidding
i don't have to know when you're kidding
i'm not kidding i got to know when
you're kidding
[Applause]
he's very good yes michael bending uh
[Applause]